so I get this call from the dr. Oz Show
and they wanted to do a whole show on
body types a whole hour
because I actually have a lot of
information on videos an internet about
body types I wrote a book on body types
it was a best-seller
been working with body types for 10
years so anyway I spent the next 30
hours straight compiling all the
research I had and body types because we
had to condense it into one hour and
make it simple so I scripted it out I
stuck stuck my jokes in there everything
for each body type and I sent it to them
so we were going to they were going to
fly me up to New York on a Friday so it
was Tuesday and I get I get an email not
even a cog an email says sorry dr. Berg
were going in a different direction
sorry we're not going to the show so I'm
like oh that was a waste of 30 hours so
a little bit pissed you know but I was
okay with it I mean I told my mom and I
told patients and things but what really
got me about a month later I get this
link from one of my patients can you see
yourself in one of these pictures you
carry your weight in your belly or you
bottom-heavy or you shape more like a
box if so you've just found the first
secret down locking your body's fat
burning furnace your body type and with
your Apple a pair or box your body type
is a direct effect on your metabolism so
today I'm giving you my secrets the
turbocharged your metabolism for your
body type dr. Jeffrey Morrison is a
nutrition specialist he studied the link
between metabolism and body type for
over 10 years welcome to the show well
dr. oz when you're 18 years old
basically you can eat just about
anything you want and your weight
doesn't change and with each decade you
get older your metabolism slows and your
hormones change as you get into your 40s
then the metabolism starts changing even
more and the hormones keep on getting
imbalanced and people's body shape will
change based on the hormones and
that gets accumulated where the hormones
are imbalanced so in your 20s anyone can
lose weight but when you get into 30s
40s and 50s
things change hormones change and your
metabolism slows down in certain
hormones will cause fat to accumulate in
the hips versus in the midsection versus
just all over the body and that also can
be a predictor for what type of health
problems a person could be at risk for
if you look around you're going to
notice that most people fall into one of
four body shapes some people hold a
weight in the stomach as a sagging belly
some people as a protruded some people
hold their weight in the saddlebag hip
area and the arms yet other people will
be big everywhere well the apple shape
but generally gains weight in their
midsection they tend to have a round
face they accumulate weight in their
upper back and they tend to have small
legs it has a lot to do with an
imbalance in a certain hormone that is
affected by stress it's called cortisol
and cortisol we all know is the stress
hormone and cortisol causes weight to
accumulate in the midsection and
especially around our organs so you can
see that this doctor is using my script
in fact nowhere on this doctors website
will you see anything about body types
he's not an expert I don't know where
they got this guy but basically he's
talking about my body types so why does
cortisol that hormone cause that
accumulation of fat especially in the
belly
well the belly has specific cortisol
receptors that soak up cortisol when
people are under stress and it directs
back to be stored underneath the stomach
in and around organs interest the thing
about an apple metabolism is that they
don't they're not the type of person
that's going to be able to go on a
low-calorie diet because that the body
would use that as a stressful experience
also excessive exercise is also
considered a neck stressful experience
for somebody that responds to stress
that way so the low calorie diet too
much exercise equals increased cortisol
level because the body is trying to be
protective of a famine type of event
well there's a number
significant health problems that people
should be concerned about inflammation
high blood pressure heart disease
diabetes and even breast cancer can you
just explain it for everybody why some
people accumulates fat in some parts of
the body and others in different parts
their body well a lot of that has to do
with different types of hormone
imbalances so with as we said with the
cortisol level with the cortisol body
type it's stored in the in the
midsection with other types of hormone
imbalances it can be stored in the hips
or also just throughout the whole body
so I'm curious I'm question for all of
you what would it mean for you to lose
your Apple shape in fact what would it
look like if you were going back to age
18 and how you appear sounds reasonable
huh get up have got a plane that is
specifically targeted can burn your
belly fat but first are you plagued with
stubborn cellulite that's a key symptom
for our next body type you need to
understand that one find out which one
it is we come back okay I'm gonna doing
my secrets the turbocharging your
metabolism for your body type and we've
already talked about the apples or
plagued with belly fat the next body
type the pear if you store fat in your
hips butt and thighs you have a
pear-shaped body like two-thirds of all
women your bottom area is the first
place you gain weight and the last place
you lose it because your body wants to
save this fat to convert for energy so
what steps can you pear-shaped women
take to trim your bottom
dr. Moore so what's up Aires biggest
challenge
well the pair's body type stores weight
on their hips thighs and butt and the
reason for this is because of an excess
of a female hormone called estrogen as
the the issue with estrogen is that
estrogen is actually produced in fat
cells and it also spikes during
pregnancy and every single menstrual
cycle so it makes it very difficult for
women that might be consuming an
imbalance diet because every single time
they're spiking their estrogen levels
they're storing fat and once they store
it it's very difficult to get off the
they're saying a moment on the lips a
lifetime on the hips speaks to this body
type explain sub DITA you're all getting
this message clearly I said why does the
pair type particularly wreak havoc with
your metabolism
well the pair body type is its evolution
so throughout evolution it was very
important for women to store fat in
their hips and thigh area because to get
ready for pregnancy the didn't pregnancy
there's a lot of fat that can be readily
used for the baby during gestation one
of the most important ones for women to
know about is osteoporosis during a
woman's menstrual years they're
producing plenty of estrogen which helps
to maintain calcium in the bone and
after menopause the estrogen levels drop
quite a bit and women are not able to
keep calcium in the bone the other
health factors include cellulite
varicose veins and also joint problems
can you change your shape over time well
you can absolutely make an impact but an
apple is almost certainly not going to
become like a pear but a pear could
become like an apple and
well with all of these hormone
imbalances they all can cause certain
health risks but this body type has the
highest health risk because it's too low
in thyroid hormone thyroid hormone is
really about metabolism for the whole
body and there's some very significant
health conditions that can occur and
people should know about such as
depression memory loss high cholesterol
and enlarged heart for my box-shaped
friends out there that's not familiar
some memory issues there cheering out
there they're chanting so how does a
thyroid affect the box-type the thyroid
hormone is really the hormone that
unlocks metabolism for the entire body
it literally is the key that turns on
the metabolism for every cell in the
body and for that reason it actually if
it's low it will slow down function for
all body organs including the brain the
heart metabolism and for that reason
also there's a lot of symptoms that can
occur with this such as difficulty
concentrating and memory changes high
cholesterol and then like dry skin dry
hair dry nails depression and even
constipation the secret for all the
apple-shaped folks out there the
turbocharged metabolism is are you ready
to eat foods that are low glycemic what
does that mean low twice emic foods are
foods that don't surge into your
bloodstream and don't spike your blood
sugar if you don't get that big spike in
blood sugar that change in your body
that those stressful hormones won't
accumulate that sugar as fat in your
belly and that you'll be able to lose it
effortlessly so here's what they change
they took all the solutions to the body
types and they basically just made up
something like for the Apple which is
the adrenal they said consume low
glycemic foods right well basically that
lowers insulin but it's not my solution
for the adrenal so the reasons you want
these high-fiber foods is they don't
bind up with the estrogen that's already
too much in your body and carry it out
through the intestinal system so it
comes out in your poop okay so you poop
won't look any different not gonna smell
different it's not gonna you know having
anything special about it but it'll have
extra estrogen being pulled out because
the fiber will have bound it just to
bind estrogen that is absolutely not
true
you don't get rid of estrogen by
consuming fiber they're so impressed
so the first food that I think you ought
to be focusing on if you're a
pear-shaped individual the turbocharged
your metabolism is edamame okay
edamame is rich in phytoestrogens do you
guys like that well that's our pear
section yeah our sections happy over
there
Anna mommy has phytoestrogens there are
a plant-type of estrogen they actually
hinder block your own estrogen from
doing things too much what's a good
thing but you want to have plant sources
competing with your own sources so that
you don't feel such a surge of that
hormone that causes you cumulation of
that down below your waist edamame will
do that naturally whole wheat pasta big
opportunity here it's a great swap out
for white pasta as well and get any
little bit of extra calories you take in
your body if you're a pear shape is
going to accumulate down there because
the body sees it as a safe alternative
this is a nice way of reducing the
amount of sugar surging into your body
and then the third tip everybody are
figs why do I love figs because they're
the fruit with perhaps the highest fiber
out there that I have personally adore
okay you like figs I do I like them even
more now it's right to make these part
of your diet and you will turbocharged
your metabolism and again I'm not giving
you ideas that work for you six months
down the road this will work for you so
here's the problem that I have it's not
that I didn't get on the show it was
that you are being fed the wrong
information information that is just
made up you're not going to get results
so then you're going to have a failure
so that's going to stack up so you want
to make sure that your information that
you get is based on truth not hype